herzlich kommt noch ein video von kanal
die wir heute mal ein bisschen in der
geschichte meines kanals zurückgehen
werden uns mal mit einer alten bekannten
beschäftigen werden wir werden quasi
eine alte bekannte anrufen einfach
fragen hey wie gehts dir was haben uns
sondern nicht mehr gesehen was passiert
diese alte bekannte ist rebecca ringst
ich habe auf meinem youtube-kanal das
muss man auch ehrlich sagen wirklich
eine unzahl an videos oder bekkering
hochgeladen und irgendwann ganz ehrlich
habe ich auch bis in das interesse an
vorder weiß ich mir gedacht habe
es ist kann auch noch immer das ist ja
auch wissen langweilig so sie verändert
sie irgendwie nicht aber jetzt leute
haben wir über vier monate pause seit
meinem letzten video recording und wir
fragen uns mit recht wie geht unsere
alten bekannten
was ist mit dir was macht sie so für
alle von euch das gedacht haben ja
bruder könnte sie möglicherweise ein
besseres prozess eingetreten sein ich
gehe davon aus dass wir bei xing
heutzutage interviews dreht oder
dokumentation nicht ganz sie schneidet
scheinbar immer noch sachen auf sagen
wir dieses video hier ein öffnen um drei
uhr nachts niemals spongebob schwammkopf
also sie schnippelt wieder in sachen
woher kommt das dieses umgeschnitten das
macht mir sorgen aber schon mal ein
mit einer neuen drei uhr nachts
challenge ihr heute dass alle dass ich
das mache und richtige richtigerweise
wird es heißen wir leute was geht ich
bin immer noch da ich bin immer noch da
auch wenn ihr euch alle wundern wie kann
es sein kann sich selber machen sind gar
nicht kannte ich kann es einfach okay
ich schneide
solange sachen auf wie diese plattformen
hier existiert lange video dateien
hochladen kann auf youtube für die
sachen abschneiden war werden die heute
um 3 uhr diese verfluchte spongebob
topia aufschneiden und jan werden mal
gucken ob da was drin sein könnte
ich würde mich immer noch heute wie
sowieso wieso haben wieso dieses
aufschneiden ganz ehrlich vista brand
ist habe ich mir sorgen mache vielleicht
besteht jetzt gar nicht ich sage ich mal
das erinnert mich an
also ist ein bisschen übertrieben aber
es ist die wahrheit ist erinnert mich an
diese vorstufe die so jetzt seid ich
hätte mich nicht sagt mich dass ich über
teilen wenn ich jetzt sage das ist
einfach mal der vergleich in meinem kopf
serie ok habe früher oder oftmals so
eine vorstufe gehabt wo sie zuerst
kleine tiere gequält haben also noch vom
ja ja das klingt jetzt falscher so meine
ich jetzt auch nicht ärgert sich dass
wir besser wenn die verbrecherin ist
irgendwas das kann man nicht sagen aber
das ist sowieso eine rede vor handlung
sache aufschneiden auf jeden fall denke
ich mal in das stimmt mit der puppe
nicht denn die sieht nicht neu aus leute
ich weiß nicht ob wir das erkennen könnt
seht ihr dass diese fussel da dran und
so weiter und ich ja ich bin
rebecca ich bin 24 oder sag mal 26 und
im heutigen video dann schneide ich eine
puppe auf was fällt uns dazu ein mit der
mit der puppe stimmt doch was nicht
ja nee nee also mit der youtube in die
fast 30 ist und stoff kuscheltiere auf
schneidet da das stimmt alles okay keine
ahnung wie nie vorher gehört aber die
wird mir einfach mit dem happy mir
mitgegeben bei mcdonald keine ahnung ich
will da war eine sache wollte ich aber
sagen leute also ich hab mir auch als
war auch ein grund dafür dass im büro in
videos aufgehört habe ich habe mir
einfach gedacht ich will auch nicht so
eine stimme sein die so auf einer person
die ganze drum hat das werde ich das
nicht meine persönliche überzeugung ich
habe ja auch gedacht war ich war ich
vielleicht zu hart mit dem bag aber in
der vergangenheit so habe ich wirklich
gedacht dann habe ich ja ja so was macht
ein bisschen ruhiger so deswegen echt
schön ob ich will heute ich mache nur
vergleiche mit serienmördern sonst gar
nix muss
das von sport app emil gewesen sein denn
ja es war sandra und vieles mehr also
fenster nicht gesehen habt schaut euch
unbedingt an
also seien sie also diese figur beim bei
mcdonald's bekommt ja ok alles klar also
dass es ist wieder dieser zyklus leute
wir erinnern uns setzt euch gedanken ich
zurück wenn ihr schon dabei war vor
sechs monaten
norwegen hat auch da irgendwie immer
sache irgendwie bekommen und dann
aufgeschnitten und dann hat sich die
nächste sache ergeben die man auf
schneiden kann und warum man nachts in
den wald rein gehen kann und von wem man
jetzt gerade verflucht und verfolgt wird
also es ist nachwievor dieses sehr
seltsame konstrukt das ist ein gutes
zeichen keine ahnung hättet ihr damit
gerechnet dass super leute ich hab
müssen weiter geschult geht durch das
geht wird das was rebecca wassers mit
spongebob gemacht das war auch ein held
von meiner kindheit als ich max von
sport stand ich war früher eher ein
paket als ein super rtl geht aber
trotzdem weder wir springen einfach
weiter der typ ist einfach da
aufgeschlitzt
was ist das neue top leute ganz ehrlich
rebecca muss so viel geld damit
verdienen ja sie muss so viel geld damit
verdienen das ist immer noch
weitermachen also ich glaub ich kann mir
das anders erklärt und ich bin mir
sicher die wird viel gestorben machen
ach ja das kann ja immer machen wollte
ich schaue auf social et da kann man ja
mal gucken wie viele klicks machen
bewegung macht 20 millionen klicks
vormonat und dann leute kann man sagen
sie macht immer videos über zehn minuten
je nachdem es ist ganz schwer zu sagen
heute aber das können sie ganz ganz ganz
easy 40 bis im aller krassesten fall
vielleicht so 160000 euro nur mit
youtube pro monat seien nur mit
spongebob aufschneiden das ist
auch wirklich schauen wir weiter was
machen sie sonst noch haargenau das
jetzt auch so neu ist sie sie hat
irgendwie tik tok jetzt auch integrierte
den kanal und macht es immer so videos
schauen niemals um drei uhr nachts
tecdax wird diese tech talks nicht
schauen und drei uhr nachts mit bff
schauen was es damit auf sich hat oha
müssen ja müssen gefährliche tik tok
sein
definitiv wird auch gerade auch das
eigentlich ein rebecca wegen titel nicht
ohne dass das wort niemals geht niemals
muss in jedem rebecca wing video drin
sein
ich habe ich was was denken ihre
zuschauerinnen so wenn sie mal so ein
wieder ohne niemals im titel macht sind
diese dann so total verwirrt dass er
geht
was ist mac i was solchen jetzt niemals
machen
ich weiß es nicht naja fun fact leute
allem sache noch zu bewegen fanpages
auch noch fand ich meine als der täter
sie sind wahrscheinlich seit acht oder
zehn oder so aber ich hab ja wirklich
viele videos ihre rektorin gemacht keine
keiner verstand über das geschrieben
keine fanpage dann höre ich vier monate
lang auf videos über sie zu machen dann
kommen wir einmal die fanpages und sagen
hör auf videos über sie zu machen
2000 die kuh da muss ich jetzt die leute
raus dieses zitat gemacht haben haben
wir so eine hand ist so war jemand
einfach so eingebildet über jahren lebt
natürlich noch lebt noch wobei hier
steht ist haben wir dies berliner live
jemand war lebendig begraben dachte ich
aber schon mal es ist nicht die
möglichkeit so
eingegraben dachte ich
[Musik]
dann weiß ich einfach nur sein kumpel it
was only get geist kann gut habe ich
mich gerade erstreckt niemals schaue ich
mir das im 83
meist ist das ja unrealistisch wie soll
man sich das anschauen das geht
überhaupt nicht also wir merken leute
bekkering behält das große thema bei
also diese masche dass man ja das klingt
jetzt müssen dramatisch aber jetzt sein
das ist die masche was man halt so
kleinen kids bisschen angst macht so
wirklich einen achtjährigen 10 jährigen
mädels nicht andenken tumor bruder also
wenn der spot man mich bei mir
vorbeikommen dann schaue ich dir mal bei
bäckereien wie man umgeht mit dem
spongebob wie man ihn richtig
aufschneidet findet er bestimmt gut also
verfluchtes stofftier fehlt es bestimmt
gut wenn man dem eine bastelschere ein
jahr
das beruhigt verfluchte wesen immer
diesen zählen danach sogar die hab ich
aufgeschnitten korrekt warum soll ich
mir dass ich in drei nachts ab sonntag
steht dritte riedroder best prank für
alle die in englisch aufgepasst haben
frank haist streich es steht doch da
unten drunter dass das nicht echt ist
was ist dann doch ein gruselig außerdem
ist es am helllichten tag
es ist ein sprengkopf warum kann ich mir
nicht um 83 können darf mir keine
experten schauen und da nachts nur noch
tagsüber backbeat also dieses großen
thema bleibt wie bei weg geht ist es
einfach so sehr als letztes video sogar
hochgeladen versuche niemals diese
whatsapp nachricht um drei uhr nachts zu
öffnen also macht sich haben wir auch
prozess wieder was mir auch gerade auf
heute die bäcker mich wirklich immer so
geistes kein überbelichtete also ticker
mein bild jetzt so sollst dich mal
rebecca den filter an machen ja ok go
leute was geht ab herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video in dem ich heute
wieder
die grüße whatsapp chats mir anschaue
deutschland schon heute damit haben wir
unsere freundin rebecca besucht und wir
können sagen über queen hat sich nicht
gebessert zuschneidet immer noch sachen
auf wie zweifeln nach wie vor an ihre
gesundheit machen wir versuchen mehr
hätte ja sein können es hätte ja sein
können dass sie sich geändert hat es war
nicht so für euch gibt es noch zwei
optionen entweder rating comparis vorbei
und schneidet euch auch für ein youtube
video oder ihr check hier drüben als für
euch vor schluss wieder ab und
harmoniert hier oben kann main kanal das
die einzige möglichkeit wer dem entgehen
könnte ich sag ich ganz ehrlich während
der stelle raus macht sachen und 318
bleibt stabil